savez-vous si vos proches sont pour ou
contre le don d'organes postmortem une
question que l'on peut tous se poser
aujourd'hui à l'occasion de la Journée
nationale de réflexion sur le don
d'organe selon l'Agence de biomédecine
au 1er janvier 2023 28
000 patients étaient encore en attente
d'une grève rencontre avec quelques
chanceux qui ont pu en bénéficier
pendant deux jours des transplantés on
sillonné notre région à vélo saragro les
a croisé lors d'une courte pause à Bléré
encore un effort il ne reste plus que
quelques mètres pour ses cyclistes avant
de franchir les portes de l'école
primaire de Bléré depuis deux jours 18
patients greffés et si soignants
pédalent ensemble pour sensibiliser le
public au nom d'organes objectif atteint
ce matin au cours d'un pique-nique avec
les élèves de CM1 ça peut permettre une
pas une nouvelle vie mais ça peut leur
rendre un organe qui j'avais perdu je
trouve ça génial qu'il y ait des
personnes c'est assez gentils qui peut
qui veulent bien donner leur organe pour
qu'il y ait quelqu'un qui puisse
survivre
sauver une vie se retraiter de 63 ans
greffé d'un rein il y a 19 ans en a bien
conscience c'est un geste et
[Musique]
mon donneur je ne le connais pas bien
évidemment parce que le l'anonymat
rigide le lion d'organe mais j'ai une
très très grande estime pour mon bonheur
et comme je dis souvent
je ne le connaissais pas et ne lui
devait rien je ne le connais toujours
pas et je lui dois tout
l'émotion est tout aussi présente chez
Alexandra la plus jeune de l'équipe il y
a à peine 8 mois cette danseuse
professionnelle de 36 ans a reçu un
nouveau cœur avant cette greffe elle
était bien loin d'être informée sur le
don d'organe j'avais jamais parlé du don
d'organe et de tissu d'ailleurs parce
que voilà il y a les tissus aussi et je
trouve que plus jeune comme ça c'est
hyper important déjà en fait à l'école
de pouvoir en discuter de pouvoir
sensibiliser plus qu'une mobilisation du
côté des soignants c'est aussi un
véritable moment de partage pour nous ça
a été très très chouette de rouler avec
ces personnes greffées parce qu'on n'a
pas souvent l'occasion de rencontrer et
de montrer bah voilà qui sont vraiment
en pleine forme qui vont bien qui qui
respire la joie de vivre et donc ça a
été souvent des très très belles
rencontres et ouais on est très très
heureux d'avoir organisé et participer à
cette manifestation
un coup d'eau pour la route il est déjà
temps de repartir dernière étape
direction tour point d'arriver finale